ah hey guys it's Danielle from the
Academy I'm the community's Academy's
community manager today is our second
Google+ Hangout as part of student
filmmaker Week which culminates with the
Student Academy Awards on Saturday today
we are gonna have some students from our
Google+ community plus some trophy
bearers from this last year's award show
they're gonna talk to our student kami
Awards producer Jennifer Todd who's in
the chat right now and the way the day's
gonna work is I'm going to introduce
Jennifer then the students are gonna
introduce themselves and then we're
gonna do a couple rounds of questions
that sound good right yeah so I am so
excited to welcome Jennifer Todd who is
produced so many shows including our
movies rather including memento the
Austin Powers films Alice in Wonderland
the upcoming Alice in Wonderland 2 as
well as our student kami Awards this
year which are gonna be hosted by Bob
Saget and I'm going to keep plugging it
on Saturday and you'll have all our
clips and quotes here on our YouTube
page and our Google+ community so thank
you so much Jennifer for coming and I
think we'll kick off with AJ I'll
introduce himself and then we'll go to
the line hi I'm AJ young I'm a scimitar
EFI major at Columbia College in Chicago
yeah it's nice weather over here
hearings coming in all the way from
Korea hi my name is Harun I'm here in
Seoul right now I'm a film major at
Emerson College and its attendant yes my
name is 210 De Russie I'm a UCLA
produces program MFA and I am coming to
you from UCLA I know you're close fine
yeah or as we like to call it a bunker
underground Tim from Salt Lake hi I'm
Tim Drake I have been attending solid
Community College I'm getting ready to
transfer out until the LA Film School
and hustle of Los Angeles City College
as a film production major and was
really excited to get my career going
great awesome
hey did you wanna start with your first
question yeah this question I've been
asking a lot of filmmakers I've been
meeting but you've obviously been an
issue for a while so maybe you might
have a better influence or idea but when
you left film school or when you started
working in the industry what were like
the first five years like mmm well I
started you know I was just about
getting in and I for me I got a job as a
receptionist working at a virtual silver
and and then about a month later his
assistant quit I went in and kind of
made my pleat and things that I could do
that and for me it was just about I
think he's in the best ways just not
being precious and just trying to get in
somewhere you know if I obviously if
you're studying cinematography it's not
gonna be as much the producing route but
so funny I'm getting used to the Google
layout 60 if I'm looking where I'm
supposed to be not looking I'm not sure
where I'm supposed to look at the camera
I'm here but anyways I think it's just
about not being precious and I think as
a cinematographer I think it's just
about finding work and whether it's you
know wherever you can kind of work on a
camera crew in whatever capacity because
you know work against work and that's
how you find relationships and that
really is when you look at careers and I
could take you through the very long and
boring history of how I got things made
but you know it really came about you
know people that I met you know people
that I met it you know my first peruse
in the years that this is still tie into
the people I know now in the jobs that I
got my sort of philosophy is like just
work as much as you can in whatever
capacity you can get in may do and
obviously do the best work you can do
because you know the movie the business
is crowded and in it and I feel like it
rises to the top you know and I feel
like the people who are are really
committed and just love film and can't
do anything but it not only survive but
really flourish and I feel like
people who are committed and serious get
condoms pushed out you know I mean
that's like just so I think so I think
that's the best advice I could give it
would just be you know try to find as
much work as you can and then it is
about you know I don't want to call
unhitch call it Network being as much as
just like building relationships you
could call them one thing they call you
again you know that kind thing and I
love tonight it really I worked as a PA
or assistant I was never precious I just
grabbed whatever jobs I could find and
trying to do and try to do a really
great job oh thank you sure and I think
I can just speak to that as well I know
that when Jennifer's joined the student
kami awards producing team the entire
marketing department over here was very
excited because I think you guys had
worked together before and had come up
in the business together yeah Christina
and I had - exactly it is a small
business so you kind of have to crack it
and then and then build your
relationships I think the centrai you
know just to be to do a great job and I
think even with simchart it's just I
would get out if that's what you want to
do I was try to get on whatever you know
cruise you could do you know reach out
to everyone you know and the most sort
of you know positive energy way you can
of like I know I'm here if you ever need
because people that's how that you know
work comes up and then hopefully they'll
think of you Oh awesome sure great
hearing yeah um so this semester I got
to work in a few films as a producer and
I really got to know get to know like
how no producers work it also really
realized how sometimes being a female
producer can work in to your advantage
so I was wondering if that still kind of
works similar ways in Hollywood in the
street you do get are there anything
like props and cons about being a female
producer well that's a long conversation
we can have about it but I think I think
the pros are I do think women I think
women are very suited to be producers
that thing reducing is about doing a
multitasking and doing many things at
once which I think women are inherently
better at than men I can speak to them
my husband
and I think in a lot of ways it's about
nurturing that creative people and I
feel like that is you know you know I'm
sort of managing expectations and all
that some per Technic women are very
good at I think the downfall is in you
know my credit curve somewhat eclectic
I've done some sort of male-driven
material or some stuff but also
female-driven but I do feel like one of
the full-backs for me is that
historically I got submitted sort of
less an action less big movies more
romantic comedies you know for years it
was always like anything female-driven
was like you know and you're one of the
only one of the more successful female
producers and I couldn't get the very
hard to tell female driven stories up to
you it's like oh well she'll know how to
crack that and a little bit less than
maybe the gangster movie that I would
still like to make you know so I feel
like that's some of the drawbacks when
you look at you know some of the bigger
and like I said action or cartooning
kind of movies they feel like they're
Ferriss they're the materials brought to
men more often than to women that's
great
do you feel like you are because you've
had such a career so far that you are
now making more of your own choices that
you get to pick more proactively oh yes
you know you know it depends on you know
it depends on the circumstance now I now
I work with Matt Damon and Ben Affleck
that's recently for like the last six
months I started running their company
so now I am in the position where I only
hit male drip and stuff fun for now it
is mix it out like you know two years
ago I made you know in these independent
films Celeste and Jesse forever and I
made this comedy to see male-driven
comedy called the to do list that comes
out this summer and so and those were
both movies he came to me I think
because of people's expectations of what
I you know then I be the right person
for them and I and I was you know I'm at
ni and I'd love those but it's like I
was getting more material like that and
definitely less of stuff I just think
inherently Studios think of men for some
of those so those kinds of films and you
know it's unfortunate it's interesting
when you would get filmmaker like you
know Kathryn Bigelow says sort of the
anomaly of a female director kind of
working in the very kind of male-driven
material but I'm sure behind her
there'll be many hopefully many more
female directors to be the same Hassan
to tender hi Jennifer
um thanks for this wonderful honor my
question is about being an international
filmmaker seeing as how the I guess the
film industry is becoming more and more
global I wonder that I'm asked what you
think is a good way for young
international filmmakers to get their
first film made and considering the fact
that you know international pre-sales
becoming more and more important and I
guess I'm wondering what you think is a
good way for a young filmmaker to get
like a feature made and what's what want
some bad ideas that you think would work
in today's marketplace yes it'd be an
english-language film something with
that's got a global concept but that
might be unique to a specific
international crowd well I actually
think it's the best time ever to try to
do that I feel like you know now that
when you look at how movies are
performing you know the the studios are
looking more for or a financier in
general looking more and more for
international ideas and co-productions
you know because we're being more and
more of our box office revenue out of it
out of international box offices you
know some some regions like China and
Russia eath right now I've seen kind of
saw the whole Iron Man 3 Chinese side
you know there is very important because
there's so much money to be had in those
territories but I think I think it's
very smart to - you know everyone's very
hungry for movies that have sort of
multi-cap of multinational actors in
them
because obviously it's like you could do
something where you could cast an
American and then a European and you
know and all that I feel like if said
you know they did great appeal right now
I actually know it's the greatest time
to try to make those kinds of movies so
all they want from us is sort of
something that has a tie-in to for does
they feel like it's more of a guarantee
if they're gonna get money problem in
those areas of the world so depending on
what kind of if it's a commercial
concept of it has action I don't know
what you know conceptually it is but I I
think it's a good time and there's a lot
of obviously those ways to skin the cat
you know depends on the material and
where you want to start but I feel like
it's it's a really strong time to try to
try to build that I think people are
very open to it you know the harder
thing to make internationally as like a
comic comedies are too hard but if it's
an action thriller a drama I think you
probably you know I think you'll have a
good start
well thank you sure awesome and Tim mom
my question is kind of in regards to how
you select the films that you've worked
on I mean you have such a wide variety
of different films that you produce what
sticks out to you when you are selecting
selecting a new project as far as the
script or the concept goes you know for
me it's interesting it's just taste but
if it's all I can to speak to the movies
that I made and they are weirdly electic
is that they were all things that when I
read them you know appeal to me in some
way I can remember I can kind of talk
about you know all of them in some way
of what it was and you know remember
when I read the script for boiler room
long while I was like well this is a
world I haven't seen I didn't know these
guys existed any of these places existed
I thought you know it was such a cool
concept I remember you know reading
Austin Powers and thinking Micah's
friend of ours I remember just thinking
it was like the funniest craziest thing
I've ever read this was this amazing
character that no one would ever heard
over for with his Ethan his glasses and
you know and and I thought it you know
just make me laugh and I was reading it
so so for me I really think it's it's
just personal taste and you know I tell
a story not to look like I'm an idiot
but just to give an example which is
like you know you know the friend of
mine was working on Twilight they needed
a pretty serous Stefan and I read the
script and I pass on the opportunity I
just didn't like the movie it was
vegetable production it didn't work for
me and now I see I would have been a
deal of money off the Twilight movies
but in truth that wasn't the right
producers for those movies I still don't
get them I don't I'm not maybe it's not
my age I don't know terrible I would
never want that and it's that's smart
though I'm you know and I have to know
what I'm good at what I'm not I wouldn't
be a good producer on that movie because
I don't know how to tell good and bad
within that genre because it doesn't
speak to me I mean there's lots of
movies I would have loved to have made
that other people made you know but I
have to I think that's one of the best
pieces of advice I could give anybody's
don't work on something because you
think people will like it work on it
because you like it like I remember
reading momento and I thought was the
craziest script I've ever read it took
me three tries it read like stereo
instructions
series it's a mostly thinking at some
point you know because the whole script
is backwards so I remember thinking at
some point oh it's gonna flip for words
you know so I was checking to take notes
to see at what point I thought wow they
really executed this thing beautifully
at the time I flew back to LA I met with
Chris Nolan I watched his first movie
the following I was like this guy's so
talented in my heart I wasn't sure
anyone would see that movie
I knew my some school geek friends liked
it but I didn't know anybody that's that
you know I mean I was like okay Adele
geeked out on this I think it's cool but
will anybody think it's cool I don't
know but I thought it was full so I was
like this is really fun let's go for it
let's see and I believed in it you know
to me to thank God it had to think but
like that's why so it's like you know
that was more of my taste so you know
what I mean it's like I momento spoke to
me Twilight did you guys over to
bacterial and something will speak to
something doesn't I also made the
mistake of trying to make something
earlier in my career I would try to make
something because people would tell me
oh that's a great idea that's a really
commercial idea it's like and then I
just realized I should never work on a
horror movie I should never work on a
Western you know there's certain things
that I don't have great passion for but
I there's a lot that I do you know and I
do do comedies and if you do dramas and
those are akin to the movies that I grew
up on or that I studied in school and
that I loved but don't waste your time
on something you just don't believe in
your heart or you don't
through the problem with that is like I
can't give notes smart notes on
something I don't seek let believe in
you know it's like I've never made a
kids movie because I'm not very good at
family and our team again I vote now in
small kids maybe I'll pick better at it
I'm not I realized you just have to
realize where your passion and your
straits lie and you don't want to waste
your time on something even if somebody
thinks it's like you know the most
commercial idea ever if it's not in your
heart
I wouldn't don't waste your time you
know okay thank you that's good advice
that is incredibly helpful AJ okay so my
next question would be is what advice
would you give to a 23 year old Jennifer
I think that's a really nice that's
really nice question I think I would say
just stick to your convictions and
probably you know try to make what you
think a little bit of what we just spoke
about don't waste your time I did waste
a lot of my time on stuff I probably
shouldn't have I think you know I lived
I would say no one to get the foot let
the politics get you down there's so
much politics in Hollywood and but I
think at the same time I might oh I was
so driven when I was young I was so
clear in what I wanted that that in that
way I would congratu
I would be I would actually count myself
on the back a little bit because I feel
like that what broke me through is just
my life never just my sort of
fearlessness at like not if it seemed
like what I wanted and being able to
push through and not taking no for an
answer you know I think that I said that
really is it there's film is such a such
a big business now it's so funny when I
went to film school there were like
three in the country you know it was
like see UCLA NYU and now it's so cool
that everybody can study film so much
you did such it's become such a big
business and really what separates
people is like great passion and
determination and yes talent but I feel
like determination in town I mean
determination is even stronger like you
know the people who couldn't really stay
out it and get at it but yeah but what
else would I tell the 22
I don't know found this you know I could
have tried to find that I think I think
I'd also just tell myself to stick to
the material it's just about the ideas
in the material you know awesome thank
you sure that's great
hearing what did you just what's your
next question so as a doctor I've been
directing a film and I got in kind of
bit of an argument with my producer a
lot so I was wondering what's your
advice on doctors on how to approach or
how to work with a cookie so why does
some of effective laser advice you can
give wasn't look what particular
even-even arguing with them about it was
it was it was a bit on budget and I was
also on a lot of you know producers
getting like paperwork done how you know
time time management and also unset how
some things didn't get through right but
it's so movies are so hard and they're
the weirdest combination because you
bring together so many people at once
and try to make a collective vision you
know and inherently there's always
somebody you know you never get it
perfect I feel like you know sometimes
it's like you have a project and you and
the writer me the first oil first phones
I mean you know the writer and I were so
on the right page and then we brought in
a director we got completely painted and
the director and I never liked our
visions were off you know but I made the
writer and I had the same vision so it's
sort of like well where do we go you
know how do we do you know how do we
handle this so that's what just inherent
making to an art form in which 40 50 a
hundred people make a movie right
because you're bringing all these people
together and that you're trying to make
something single on you as the director
it really is your vision you know and I
think that's the best thing you could
try to find a producer and it might be
about that this person might not be the
best collaborator for you in the future
it's really just about finding people
who who line up the same way as you you
know who really really see the films you
don't see it so that way you're all
working to a common goal you know I
don't know in the
it's just I think dealing with your
producer now I would say it's just about
trying to get it you know get it on get
it on the screen and get it done and
what's the best way to do that you know
and obviously there's it's it's so hard
though our movies it's so hard with
personalities and trying to like you
know manage them all while you're trying
to be this incredibly creative thing
these questions are fantastic they are
very very focused a very producer focus
there thanks guys for doing some
research beforehand
Jitender yeah um I was so I've grown up
in Zimbabwe I absolutely fell in love
with Austin Powers and I was just you
know fascinated by it and so I wanted to
ask you what it was like working on that
film and which is sort of like a bigger
creatures like a franchise and
how that experience differed from
working on another film which I really
loved
memento which is more smaller more I
guess if you will independence expy well
the funny thing is the first custom
powers was kind of a lower budget comedy
it wasn't it wasn't if it didn't start
out a franchise and in truth if you ask
any of us while we were making the first
movie none of us had a clue there were
ever be two wasn't designed that way you
know it ended up you know in all these
movies it's so funny in hindsight or we
you know my sister and I placed two
priests with my sister knew Mike Myers
socially through France a little bit and
so he gave us the draft of the script
and the first script was really more of
a bomb suits and a little less swinger
and a little more bog and funny enough
this is where it's all so crazy there
was this Leslie Nielsen comedy coming
out called spy heart that was a spoof
movie that was coming out soon and so we
we said you know what there's this this
one's already coming out and it's got a
lot of the same sort of spy you know
jokes to it maybe we should work on the
swinger part of it and so we all got
together we watched all these crazy
Italian like foreign comedies like
that's where we stole some of the cheap
effects of when you
right behind the rock and like the door
here you know first of all we stole
everything that's the thing about some
of the great artists I know they're not
afraid to go back and reference old
movies and take what's great about them
I don't mean dialogue you know oh the
way they did this funny effective things
like that that's what we didn't and in
truth that's why the script ended up
being what it was is literally we were
compensating for another movie we were
worried that would step on ours and so
and the other thing about my because
he's super challenging to work with but
he is always trying to make the movie
better and we had hired this guy named
Chris dorita's who did this show Morning
Becomes eclectic on on the logo Mattel
on the radio station here on I'm dating
myself and he brought in a bunch of
music for fun for us to listen to and
one of the songs was soul bossa nova and
Mike was like I love this song I think
we need to do something with it he went
home and wrote the Marches and sequence
that went at the front you know which
wasn't in the original script and so we
just allow ourselves to keep playing and
keep trying to make it funny but I
remember one day on the set my sister
and I worked I was in the assistant when
I worked for Joel Silver I've worked on
this movie Hudson Hawk and and my sister
were talking to she was just pretty sure
it was you know it's a quick sort of
famous one of those movies but there was
a shooting and dr. Evil's lair and there
was this like brain jell-o molds on the
table and it just seemed goofy weird it
she turned to me and she's like are we
making a Hudson Hawk and I was like I
have no idea okay we're trying to make
it funny but we were never confident
that we were getting it done like we
just didn't know and and so it's so
funny in hindsight you know the movie
came out it did really well but it
really did very well semester I made a
few 50 something domestic but then it
had this huge DVD release and that's
what really drove the next two movies
like I said if you control about the
time and ask me I would have given you
my firstborn child to tell you they're
like there's no way or ever making a
sequel to this movie
we were just trying to challenge
ourselves we were trying to make
themselves laugh on the day and get it
kind of speaks to that like that movie
was in all of our taste J means an mic
we were all trying to make the same
movie and the best idea on the day kind
of won and we were all just kind of in
it together you know and mmm and the
Mentos look it was the same team was a
very little bit of a different
experience but a little bit the same and
it was very pure in spirit we were all
there we all kind of believed in Chris's
vision and funny thing about that movie
is it actually we we had we made it
independently not nearly as cheap as
independent is now I can we made it
before and now I'm making movies for
like a million dollars go button but at
the time he shot it on film
and so you know it was didn't feel big
but we finished the film and we speeded
for distributors innate or nobody bought
the film like ice cream I sat on it with
Harvey Weinstein he passed to my face
and said that guys really talented that
the movies not for us and we had
screenings all over town the same night
no one wanted to buy the film and
release it and hang on the two guys
would finance it decided to release it
themselves and they put it took million
dollars their own money and they hired
the scribe Bob Bernie who was a
consultant at the time to put the movie
in theaters and then it had his life you
know but it almost went straight to
video
you know whoa nobody believed in it it's
amazing and it was so funny because then
people circle back and tell it once the
movies successful everyone changes the
story yeah I really catch on you know
it's funny when people ask me about
movies they're almost like children like
I love them all the same you know some
of them were more successful and some of
them are creatively came together but as
a producer I put I put the same energy
into all of them you know and I tried my
best to make them all be the best that
they could be if some of them came
together you know the stars aligned for
different reasons but you know it's just
about like I said about your vision and
really really believing in what you have
and then and like and then I was saying
to heroin it's about putting the team
together that you think can best do that
and it's very hard because teams are
movies are huge you're hiring a DP or
I'm a production designer your you know
your editor it's like at some point
you're gonna have conflict and you're
gonna have to feed I feel like if you
can resolve it can you guys get on the
same page do you need to make change you
know that's all the politics that comes
with movies and it is ripe with politics
you know and some filmmakers you know I
need a film with Julie Taymor who is a
great town of the chief he doesn't work
well with others and as someone's not
gonna be like you should if you want to
paint paint because now you can do by
yourself you know you could be a
sculptor but if you're gonna make movies
it's a village you know and and you and
you and me as the pretty sure I have to
just try to assemble the village the
best that I can and obviously once you
can get experience and you have commutes
with people that's why you work so hard
to bring those same people back into
your to your village to help you make
your film you know
anyways I ran them so I hope I gave you
these stories are fantastic like they're
it's so really helpful to the students I
think Desmond chairman just to hear the
background of house of our favorite
movies got made especially cuz I know
like at least three of you are in the
middle of making your thesis or your
very end film coming out of school yeah
yeah well it's funny awesome powers Jay
Roach taught one of my classes at USC he
taught a class called motion picture
camera and my sister who's older than me
NFC film school she had produced his 480
which is their thesis film their
underrated or thesis film and not family
knew him and Lily you know years later
we couldn't find anyone who wanted to
direct Austin Powers at the time we
scared a lot of people off because he
was like wrote and starred in it and a
lot of big honey directors were scared
of it so that's how we actually got Jay
the job so you never know you might you
know you might be making films with some
of these people especially you know the
people that you like you're working with
right now you know mm-hmm
that's awesome yeah so we have one last
question from Tim and then we'll finish
up okay well with me getting ready to
make the big move out to Hollywood you
know from moving from somewhere small
conservative like Salt Lake to the big
the big
so what advice would you have to
somebody's starting out and I mean you
talked a little about you know the
networking and just getting in there but
what what advice do you have to be able
to stand out from the rest of the pack
when you know trying to make yourself
known and not get swallowed up in all of
it I really think it's just about
putting in that like 110% for me it was
like I and you know like I said I would
go back in time I almost found myself
like my conviction I wanted it so badly
that I would work for anybody show up
early stay late no job is too small for
me I just literally just said like you
know I'm here I'm not going away like
you know let me do whatever I can do to
help and and I feel like you know if you
come out here is about that it's about
emailing everybody you know about
sending out your resumes it's about and
then you know once we get a job it's
just about proving yourself as somebody
that they want to have back around you
know it's funny I always talk about a
generational things I have you know I
think it's like I not know helicopter
parenting I come before that you know
it's sort of and I feel like sometimes
like I meet these interns that are
companies you guys that they're like
yeah I wanna work in film I think it's
cool but they're like you speak to them
and they don't come at you with like
passion and conviction and I just I'm
not convinced that that like that I'm
gonna know them in 20 years I think that
you know I mean I just don't think that
I don't think the business tolerates
sort of indifferent so I just feel like
you got to come out here it come strong
in conviction should just be great and
just be willing to be helpful and be and
being flexible it's like you can lose my
cheese you know the book it's a little
bit about you know I want to work in
this department but there's no jobs for
me but there's a job for me over here so
I'm gonna take that and I'm gonna be
great at it I'm gonna do the best job I
can and then those people will see me
and eventually I'll get back to where I
want to be you know I mean if I feel
like you have to have that attitude of
just getting in just literally just
being positive and good at whatever is
asked of you literally leads you to the
top I see you with assistance all the
time where you see these you know people
who work on desks in our office and the
ones who are like great and they stay I
don't mind saying the after-hour do you
need me to get that script out I can
stay here and do that those
you're like when you have another child
like okay let's grab that one you know
it so it's that easy really but I know
it sounds sort of sounds obvious but but
it's not when I see people interacting
you know it's like everyone always
everyone always has drawings of the
person who's like comes comes ready to
fight you know okay great and small like
that it's not that big of them I mean
it's not it's not a big energy [ __ ] do
you spend any time at Sundance or the
Institute or anything no not really and
I've been I've been up at the festival
the last few years and met with a couple
people at the Film Commission just
briefly as we talked to them at the
little Hut that they had there this last
year but I haven't really been able to
be involved much with it yet they have
great labs Sundance they you know if you
ever need to workshop the screenplay or
or they also understand photography lab
there they're pretty impressive a friend
of mine carry equipment runs runs the
Institute now and I if you ever if you
guys are ever looking for other places
to you know sort of warm up script or
anything like that I highly suggest you
look at Sundance and film independent
because they both have very successful
labs they have grants you know they're
kind of a great transition area place
when you're coming out of school you
know if the student we're gonna take the
students are going there this week that
won the Academy Awards and I just think
they're good venue to check out you know
their website or whatever and you might
have something that you know is a good
way to kind of plug in keep working on a
project meet more people or and that's
the same kind of transitionary okay
great
absolutely and know that we're live
logging their entire experience so if
you want to check out Oscars dot org
we'll have all the links for all like
Sundance and film independent and the SC
and WGA where all the kids are going
this week as well okay so thank you very
much Jennifer we really appreciate you
thank you and well this wraps up our
student filmmaker week hangout series so
thanks everybody and come on back on
Saturday well we'll have clips from the
show that Jennifer's producing as well
as
as well as the winners list on Oscars of
Arc thanks so much guys thank you thank
you thank you very much